und jetzt das heute journal
zweieinhalb tausend kilometer
erdgasleitungen von russland bis
deutschland auf den boden der ostsee
legen ein riesenprojekt technisch
gesehen ein riesenerfolg
kurz vor der vollendung nur politisch
fährt das ganze gerade vor eine wand
die usa setzten alles daran dieses
projekt zu stoppen weil es deutschlands
abhängigkeit von russischen
energieströmen ins unerträgliche
steigere
guten abend diese entwicklung passt nun
aber nicht in ein simples schema trump
gegen den rest der welt
auch präsident barack obama war schon
gegen dieses projekt und die eu ist
darüber gespalten
deutschland hat sich nicht beeindrucken
lassen und das projekt schon zu 90
prozent durch gezogen mit obama hätte
man so was vielleicht riskieren können
aber trump ist aus anderem holz zögert
nicht zu werkzeugen zu greifen die us
regierung bisher für staaten bereit
hielten die sie shoppen staaten nannten
deutsche energiepolitik hat jetzt ein
massives und teures problem
cornelia schiemenz berichtet es ist
unterschrieben jubel unter seinen
anhängern
heute nacht um 1 uhr 30 deutscher zeit
hat donald trump die nächste
eskalationsstufe in den
transatlantischen beziehungen gezündet
mit der unterschrift unter das sanktions
gesetz ist der weg frei für sanktionen
gegen alle firmen die beim bau der
ostseepipeline nord stream 2 beteiligt
sind für die bundesregierung ein harter
schlag aber gegenmaßnahmen lehnt
vizekanzler olaf scholz in der ard
vorerst ab es ist jetzt erst mal sache
des unternehmens und der unternehmen die
an dem bau beteiligt sind die nächsten
entscheidungen zu treffen für uns ist
klar dass wir das nicht akzeptieren
werden dass eine solche sanktion
verhängt wird und der amerikanischen
regierung das auch in allen gesprächen
und bei allen gelegenheiten deutlich
machen werden
die firma ossis die mit spezialschiffen
die rohre durch die ostsee verlegt
reagiert auf die sanktionen umgehend und
teilt gleich am morgen mit die arbeiten
an der pipeline zu unterbrechen
nord stream 2 verläuft von russland nach
lubmin bei greifswald 1200 kilometer
vorbei
in polen und der ukraine 55 milliarden
kubikmeter erdgas sollen dann jährlich
nach deutschland und von dort weiter
nach europa fließen gesamtkosten 9,5
milliarden euro
auch den amerikanern werden
wirtschaftliche interessen nach gesagt
ich werde den verdacht nicht los dass
die amerikaner vor allem darauf erpicht
sind ihr eigenes gas nach deutschland
und europa zu exportieren
das ist aber definitiv noch teurer als
gas aus russland deshalb entscheiden wir
in europa selber von wem ihr gas oder öl
oder was auch immer kaufen wollen die
amerikaner lehnen die ostseepipeline
seit jahren ab ihr offizielles argument
deutschland und europa begeben sich in
abhängigkeit von russland damit würden
sicherheitsinteressen der usa verletzt
diese sanktionen sind eine weitere
edition für eine belastung des
transatlantischen verhältnisses sie sind
nicht gut
aber schauen sie noch einmal sie kommen
ja nicht überraschend man konnte sich
darauf einstellen nord stream 2 war von
anfang an ein politikum nicht nur weil
sich viele osteuropäische länder
übergangen fühlen deutschland ist durch
diese pipeline spielball im spiel
zwischen den usa und russland geworden
diese situation ist äußerst schwierig
und das interesse an dieser pipeline hat
vor allem der russische staat der damit
seine vormachtstellung gegenüber der
ukraine und weißrussland festigen kann
deutschland hat weder ökonomisch noch
ökologisch noch außenpolitisch einen
großen nutzen von dieser pipeline
die pipeline wird wohl trotzdem kommen
es wird teurer es wird später aber es
wird irgendwann davon zeigte man sich
heute in berlin und moskau überzeugt
für etwa zwei stunden gab es
beunruhigende meldungen aus berlin vom
breitscheidplatz unsere berliner
reporter waren sofort dort der
weihnachtsmarkt wurde evakuiert
inzwischen hat sich das geklärt es war
nichts aber der breitscheidplatz bleibt
ein empfindlicher punkt drei jahre nach
dem todbringenden anschlag dort und
deshalb beginnen die nachrichten von
heinz wolf damit anlass für diese
räumung des weihnachtsmarktes war
offenbar dass zwei männer als verdächtig
auf vielen sie wurden von der polizei
befragt ein verdacht einer der beiden
könnte auf einer fahndungsliste stehen
bestätigte sich aber nicht
laut polizei hatten alle besucher den
weihnachtsmarkt ruhig und besonnen
verlassen
auch eine veranstaltung in der
kaiser-wilhelm-gedächtniskirche wurde
vorzeitig beendet
die polizei hat den weihnachtsmarkt dann
auf möglichen sprengstoff abgesucht es
wurde aber nichts gefunden
während im norden syriens die truppen
von machthaber assad ihre angriffe in
der region idleb wieder verstärkt haben
gibt es im weltsicherheitsrat streit
über die humanitäre hilfe für die
menschen im land anlass ist die frage wo
an welchem grenzübergängen die hilfe ins
land gebracht werden darf russland und
china blockierten mit ihrem veto eine
einigung was unter anderem von den usa
heftig kritisiert wurde
russland ist einer der wichtigsten
verbündeten aus und nutzt immer wieder
sein vetorecht alles um syrien geht das
derzeitige mandat für die un hilfe läuft
am 10
januar aus die usa haben in ihrem
militär jetzt eine weitere eigenständige
teilstreitkraft für konflikte im
weltraum präsident trump hat die gesetze
für diese space fonds nach der
verabschiedung durch den kongress jetzt
unterzeichnet er sagte inmitten
gravierender bedrohungen für die
nationale sicherheit der usa sei die
amerikanische überlegenheit im weltraum
absolut unerlässlich
in indien gehen die gewaltsamen proteste
gegen ein neues einbürgerungs gesetz
weiter es sind bereits mehr als 20
menschen ums leben gekommen
bei auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und sicherheitskräften im
norden des landes sollen allein heute
neun menschen ums leben gekommen sein
die demonstranten werfen der regierung
vor muslime zu diskriminieren weil für
sie die neue einbürgerungs möglichkeit
nicht gilt
österreich urlauber die per auto oder
motorrad das bundesland tirol
durchqueren müssen wie der regionale
fahrverbote beachten
die regelungen gelten seit heute bis
ostermontag jeweils tagsüber am
wochenende und an feiertagen
sie sollen verhindern dass etwa bei
autobahnstaus die fahrer massenhaft auf
landstraßen ausweichen
die sperren gelten für transitreisende
auf strecken um heute innsbruck und
kufstein
wir sind eine nachrichtensendungen die
sich auch für andere themen der
gesellschaft interessiert als zum
beispiel politik zum beispiel am vierten
adventswochenende einige der schönsten
weihnachtssongs feiern das
zusammenkommen die reisen zur oma zur
fernen geliebten zur familie
das kann gerne auch mal ein bisschen
schmutzig sein es gibt menschen denen
das weh tut weil sie einsam sind
das sind sie meist im rest des jahres
auch aber der kontrast zur gemeinsamkeit
seligkeit der glücklichen streut salz in
ihre wunden
da braucht es hilfe es gibt sie manchmal
wenigstens es könnte mehr sein
barbara lueg erinnert daran welche worte
umschreiben dieses gefühl am besten groß
quälend
bleiern übermächtig er steigt kennt
dieses gefühl zehn jahre pflegte sie
ihren mann bis er starb
kinder und enkel kommen klar aber diese
langen fallen stunden eben auch ist
allein mal einsam
ja das wäre ist schlimm etwa jeder
zehnte in deutschland fühlt sich einsam
in einer gesellschaft in der
vereinzelung immer weiter zunimmt
eine dramatische entwicklung der letzte
studien zeigen einsamkeit hat nicht nur
seelische sondern auch körperliche
folgen
sie löst stress aus und ein chronisch
erhöhter stresspegel schwächt das
immunsystem und befeuert die
anfälligkeit für beispielsweise
herzinfarkt und schlaganfall
hier kommen eben viele risikofaktoren
zusammen verglichen mit bluthochdruck
übergewicht rauchen oder alkohol trinken
ist einsam sein das gefühl einsam zu
sein
weitaus todbringender alles aufgrund
dieses gefühls mein soziales system ist
nicht so wie es vielleicht sein könnte
weil das problem in großbritannien
genauso drängend ist richtete die
britische regierung 2018 als erstes land
weltweit ein ministerium gegen
einsamkeit ein
hier können hausärzte menschliche
gesellschaft auf rezept verschreiben
doch auch die deutsche politik denkt
inzwischen über so etwas wie einsamkeit
beauftragte nach das müsste eine gruppe
von menschen geben in der politik wie
das alles koordiniert und schaut wo
ergeben gesetze eine möglichkeit
einsamkeit zu bekämpfen weil das dann so
starker risikofaktor und das hat eine so
große bedeutung für also das gemeinwohl
in unserer gesellschaft dass wir das
thema aus meiner sicht bündeln müssten
aber noch federn im alltag vor allem
ehrenamtliche die nöte einsamer menschen
ab hannelore botzenhardt besucht seit 17
jahren im krankenhaus als so genannte
grüne dame patienten und hört ihnen
einfach zu ein sehr gutes umgehen mit
alten einsamen menschen
man muss wirklich auf die menschen
zugehen und jedes freundliche wort und
jedes hilfen zaubert vielleicht auch ein
lächeln in die gesichter dieser menschen
das hat auch jeder stein mit der
lichtblick seniorenhilfe erlebt der
verein kümmert sich um ältere menschen
die von einsamkeit eben besonders
betroffen sind die 72 jährige möchte
ihre erfahrung heute auch anderen ans
herz legen denke ich auch dahin gehen wo
andere menschen sind mal soll das schon
offen sein auch für irgendetwas welches
wort ihr gefühl an diesem tag am besten
umschreibt hoffnung vielleicht noch
einmal nachricht der viermalige schwimm
olympiasieger roland matthes ist
gestorben im alter von 69 jahren
der gebürtige thüringer galt zu seiner
zeit als weltbeste holten schwimmer bei
den olympischen spielen 68 und 72 gewann
er jeweils gold über 100 und 200 meter
rücken
zudem war er mehrfacher welt- und
europameister
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
4 13 14 20 27 35 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56
und jetzt die wetteraussichten morgen
gibt es im osten einige auflockerungen
und es bleibt meist trocken sonst ist
der himmel grau und von südwesten her
zieht regen auf
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 5
und 10 grad und die weiteren aussichten
bis weihnachten bleibt es oft bedeckt
windig und regnerisch mit vier bis zwölf
grad ist es für die jahreszeit zu mild
zu fällt schnee oberhalb von rund 900
metern
diese karte ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht gerade ein publikumsmagnet das
wissen wir
das heilige land steht schon zu lange
für heillose konflikte dabei ist das
eine der faszinierendsten regionen der
erde mit wunderbaren menschen auf beiden
seiten des großen konflikt und es gibt
da eine legendäre straße die diese sagen
wir mal reizvolle landschaft durchquert
und verbindet wie die route 66 die usa
nur einiges kürzer und hat eine andere
nummer
roth nein nicola albrecht hat diese
straße bereist und kommt zurück mit
großartigen bildern und wunderbaren
geschichten
wir sind unterwegs auf der legendären
roten ein team fahren einmal von norden
nach süden durchs heilige land ein stopp
auf unserer strecke der tiefste punkt
der erde
das tote meer eine postkarten landschaft
scheinbar unberührte natur
doch die bilder täuschen denn das tote
meer trocknet langsam aus eine frage der
zeit bis es verschwindet aus der luft
wird sichtbar immer mehr salz säulen
ragen wie pilze aus dem wasser mitten
darauf elias lilly ist geologe das tote
meer seit 40 jahren sein spezialgebiet
sein freund jackie nimmt ihn seit
jahrzehnten mit aufs wasser
beide männer leben am toten meer und das
tote meer ist ihr leben als forscher
kann ich nur feststellen
im toten meer geht es wirklich immer
schlechter und eine bedrohung sind die
single link löcher sind riesige krater
wie diese überall tun sie sich auf wo
sich das meer wegen wassermangels
zurückgezogen hat wenn die hohlräume
einsacken können sie straßen auch die
rot
ganze häuser verschlucken die schönsten
strände mussten wegen dieser gefahr
bereits geschlossen werden
das tut weh weil wir das nie wieder
rückgängig machen können das ist so
absurd wir sind hier in einer region mit
wenigen einwohnern
offenbar sind wir nicht siegen nicht
laut genug
li und jackie bleiben ein leben ohne das
tote meer für sie unvorstellbar
im süden israels führt sie durch die
wüste aber wer hier leben möchte braucht
einen besonderen geist den geist der
urväter israels sagen die menschen hier
oder den der besten yogis meinen sie
einmal im jahr treffen sich mehr als
1000 yoga begeisterte mitten in der
israelischen wüste
das klingt balance das beruhigt in
unserem land kann es nicht schaden etwas
zurück zu kommen zur ruhe zu kommen
heißt hier in der wüste an diesem abend
dann allerdings loslassen und den moment
feiern
trotz oder gerade wegen allem am
vorabend von heiligabend montag 19.25
läuft die ganze geschichte mit ihren
starken bildern bei uns im programm
zwischen shalom und salat oder auch
jetzt schon und wann immer sie wollen in
der mediathek auf zdf.de wir wünschen
eine gute nacht und einen friedvollen
sonntag bis bald wieder sehen
[Musik]